now the US Senate has opened debate on a
resolution to start the repeal of
President Obama's legacy defining health
care law Vice president-elect Mike Pence
says he expects Congress will come up
with a plan for the Affordable Care Act
replacement in the months ahead we're
joined now by professor of political
science at Peter Mathews who's in Long
Beach in California he's the author of
the recently published book dollar
democracy good morning to you professor
Matthews thank you for joining us here
on Sky News this has got to be so
galling for President Obama watching
what he achieved in spite of Republican
resistance at the time about to
disappear is it likely at all that
Obamacare might survive votes in
Congress I think even survives it would
be partial survival it won't be a full
survival because Republicans have the
majority and they're using a process
called Budget Reconciliation to actually
pass it through the process of getting
rid of Obamacare as fast as they can and
the way it works is that the house and
actually the Senate's of the key body
the Senate the Senate would say to the
people there go ahead and let's pass a
resolution and instead to do with
reconciliation which means that all you
have to do is is make say to the about
four committees in the Senate the top
committees are involved with health care
legislation you need to cut out 1
billion dollars to the budget deficit
next year and once that general
blueprint is set up then the specific
legislation to implement the blueprint
to actually start the cutting of the
budget deficit will go into place and it
only takes 51 votes if there's a full be
a majority of the whole Senate in place
the punt centers are there it's only a
majority vote that it takes not if not a
60-percent vote as it would in other
cases so this is a way to reduce the
number of votes actually needed to
actually pass the various laws that
would implement this deficit reduction
or implement the cutting of the
Obamacare programs and that's what
they're going to be using is a type of
tactica let us say a tactic to get this
done even more quickly and the deadline
they've said is January 27th to get it
done by january twenty seven so parts of
obamacare could actually start being
eliminated as early as january 27th in
terms of the actual passage of the
legislation it's a very interesting way
but they can only do these you have so
many Republicans in the House and Senate
the majority I've actually
yeah and the Republicans and indeed the
president-elect Donald Trump have all
said that they would like to keep some
aspects of Obamacare which aspects you
think they should keep and why well I
personally should keep all of them and
then expand on them and make the United
States have a comprehensive universal
system like all the other countries are
civilized in the world written for
example you have the NHS you have
single-payer health care in Canada
Medicare for all we need to have some
light over here and I think that if they
do keep some of those portions of it
they must at least keep the part that
says that no insurance dummy can kick
you off the plan just because you have a
pre-existing condition and also that
young people who are on the age under
the age of 26 can remain on their
parent's insurance until they're 26
years old these are all very incremental
steps of Obama took and in my book
dollar democracy I see at the chapter on
health health care I call Obamacare a
small step in the right direction it
should have been expanded to a public
option or a single pair type of
nonprofit medical insurance system as in
canada medicare for all as we have here
for the elderly that would be the way to
go in my opinion but seeing Republicans
the majority than Donald Trump coming in
as a Republican president it's gonna be
very tough for anybody anything done in
that direction so more than likely we'll
start see some cuts of Obamacare and
some real revisions to it not entirely
though well you mentioned the NHS here
in the UK I mean we're very used to the
idea of universal health care here it
seems like a no-brainer to us why has
Obamacare been so controversial in the
US because mainly of the lobbyists the
various wealthy lobbying groups that
donate money to campaigns to members of
Congress got elected with their money
and then they owe these lobbyists
something's health insurance industry
lobbyists the used to be the American
Medical Association one time is to be
against it the universal healthcare they
were lobbyists lobbyists from the
pharmaceutical companies drug companies
all these very special interest groups
of a be able to keep away a concept of
universal health care and to vilify as
being socialized medicine well frankly
most of our allies have socialized
medicine or some forms within as
candidate us and it works very well
those countries like Britain and Canada
have longer life expectancy the United
States people itself we have shorter
life expectancy we have a larger rates
of infant
here in this Canada and other countries
and we have other kinds of problems that
the outcomes of which are a result of
not having universal health care even
with Obamacare today being implemented
about 30 million American 20 million
Americans are left uncovered and if this
the Republicans repeal the entire
Obamacare 20 million Americans you
actually receive coverage will lose
their coverage as well so totally 50
million Americans that should actually
be covered fully are only partially
covered now and about 30 more million
would lose their coverage entirely and
that's not good at all for anyone they
make all of us even those of us who have
health care even more in jeopardy of our
health when people around us are not
healthy and it's just not a humane thing
to do so that's why would urge President
Donald Trump to go in the other
direction say look let's expand it make
it efficient single-payer nonprofit
health insurance as in Canada as we have
for the elderly year lower overhead
costs no deductibles local payments and
people will go see the doctor more
regularly and get preventive care and
live longer and that'd be the way to go
for America yeah indeed we'll have to
wait and see exactly how long it takes
and exactly what happens for now though
Peter Mathews great to talk to you thank
you for joining us here on Sky News